Salut zusammen, ich bin Fabio von Frewings und ich lege heute zusammen das Thema Meteo an.
Es geht vor allem um eine Prüfungsfarbe-reitung oder Meteo Basics generell.
Es gibt vermäßlich wie in der Meteologie zwei Arten, wie man lernen kann.
Es ist ein Teil der Minimum-Ufwand, irgendwie Diotheorieprüfung.
Und da gibt es natürlich sehr viele mehr Wetterwissen,
die man auch von mittleren und man kann lernen.
Dar gibt es eigentlich fast keine Grenzen.
Da gibt es 5 Dektor-Überräder über Meteo-Logie.
Der Kurs ist jetzt aber so, dass es wirklich auf Basics ausgeleitet ist.
Der Kurs eigentlich nicht sich sicher auch für schon prävitiierte Piloten.
Zum vielleicht das Wetterwissen wieder nach Lied auffrischen.
Zum neuen Sachen dazu zu lernen.
Es hat sicher auch viel Spannende Gebiet dabei für prävitiierte Piloten.
Aber der Kurs ist natürlich vor allem auch auf Flugschirren ausgeleitet.
So, dass man auch hoffentlich das Wetterwissen gut von mittleren können.
Wo im Theorie, wo ich vielleicht in der Trocken ist
und Menge Sachen schirrigt zum Verstoß sind.
Und so stieg man auch jetzt mal hier.
In der Spannende Gebiet vom Wetterwissen.
Ein Thema, das wir auch immer ganz am Herzen liegt,
vor allem wenn es um Meteo-Logie geht,
ist, dass es zwei Bereiche gibt.
Eine theoretische Wetterwissen,
wo man vielmehr, viel Theorie auch versteht.
Aber gerade in der Trocken-Logie spielt sich ein Wetter,
für die sehr viele Erfahrungen zu tun.
In der Flutie-Fraxis oder in der Meteo-Fraxis.
Sehr viele mit der Flutie zu tun.
Das Wetter wird immer wieder beobachtet, analysiert.
Und die Theorie mit der Praxis auch immer wieder abgleicht.
Und das ist auch ganz wichtig.
In diesem Bereich geht es aber tatsächlich um Theorie
und um ein gewisses Grundverständnis für das Wetter.
Vor allem, ob ich beim Größten bin,
wo spielt sich das Wetter ab?
Das ist unsere Atmosphäre.
Atmosphäre rund um die Welt ist aufteilt
in verschiedenen Gebiet.
Die Stratosphäre, mesosphäre, troposphäre.
Für uns, aber am relevantesten,
ist ein troposphäre,
wo auch bei Gränsen,
mit der troposphäuser,
und in dieser Schicht,
befinden sich die meisten Luftführechtigkeit,
da oder da auch die meisten Wasserdampfe.
Und so mit der Wetter,
die troposphäre,
ist extrem dünn,
weil das Wetter um die Welt umherbaut,
also so auch die Strasse,
die die Strasse,
die Strasse,
die Zwiebelschälfere,
das ist wirklich ganz, ganz dünne Bereich,
wo sich der Wetter geschehen abspielt
und wo man es natürlich auch bewegt.
Und mir als Gletschermüger
bewegt sich sogar nur
in der unterste Schicht
von dieser troposphäre.
Und da wichtig in der Thürie,
dann bin ich da für Thürie,
ich wusste,
die Zemensetzung
von der Gas in dieser troposphäre,
ist das,
sind das die 21%-Zurstoffen,
weil für uns wichtig sind,
zum Schnuffen natürlich,
die 18-17%-Stickstoff
und dann gibt es noch 1%-Edel-Gas,
wo zum Beispiel auch gar nicht zu akkört,
das ist aber für uns jetzt
für die Metrologie,
nicht für große Relevanz,
die restlichen Edelgas,
oder drin sind.
Dann,
troposphäre,
die ist nicht rund
unter Globus gleich dick,
die ist auch der Pole
oben ein bisschen dünner,
wie auch der Equator,
da hat mit der Erdrotation zu tun.
Am Equator ist die ungefähr 18 Kilometer
und ein Pole
oben ungefähr 8 Kilometer.
Bei uns in Europa
von der Breite gerade her,
wo wir ja viel am Flüge sind,
sage ich,
ungefähr 11 bis 13 Kilometer,
dicke von dieser troposphäre,
zum Beispiel die 13.000 Meter.
Dann,
wieder mal von einer Standratatmusphäre,
das ist immer wieder wichtig,
im Flugwetter
oder v.a. die Theorieprüfung,
fragen Sie immer wieder aus,
über die Standratatmusphäre.
Das ist diese Atmosphäre,
wenn sich das Wetter
komplett ausgleichen,
wir haben keine Hochdruckgebiet,
die Tüftdruckgebiet,
und verschiedene Faktoren,
die wir uns aus weitem beeinflussen.
Jetzt werden wir da schauen.
Wenn sich alles wieder ausgleichen,
dann kämpfen wir auf eine sogenannte Standratatmusphäre.
Das ist so wieder null punkt,
was sich alles ausgleichen hat.
Und da gibt es ein paar Zahlen
und Fekts,
wo wir den Theorieprüfung abrufen.
Das Wichtige ist ein Temperaturgradient in der Höhe,
wie sich die Trupposphäre abkühlt.
Und zwar redet man da von 60,5 Grad,
pro 1000 Höhemeter,
oder pro 100 Meter,
indem man sprechen kann,
0,65 Grad pro 100 Meter.
Dennoch an der Erde,
ob er vielleicht in der Standratatmusphäre
redet man von 15 Grad
und an der Truppospause
ob er von den Minus 56 Grad.
V.a. die 102 Zahlen sind wichtig,
also wir lernen für die Theorieprüfung.
Die Temperaturgradient
ist natürlich noch ein Wetter lag,
und die Situation,
wenn man später lernen,
kann er natürlich variieren.
Aber wir die Standratatmusphäre redet man von 60,5 Grad,
pro 100 Meter.
Da hat man die Temperatur,
in der Standratatmusphäre redet man auch,
ob er eine Standratatmusphäre,
und die Zahlen,
die auch immer wieder werden gehören,
sind die 2013,25 Hectopascalle.
Der Luftdruck,
wenn sich die ganze Trapposphäre
ausgleichen,
dennoch an einem auf mehren Höhen gerechnet,
der Luftdruck immer gleich,
und dann auf den 2013,25 Hectopascalle.
Und der Tropposphäre,
höchig,
der Troppospause in den Anfang,
ist bei 11 Kilometer in der Standratatmusphäre.
Denn beim Luftdruck auch wichtig,
wie ein Sinktädenhöchig,
da ist nicht linear,
und zwar gibt es da ein Fustregler.
Da kann man sagen,
dass sich alle 5.500 Meter in der Höhe
der Luftdruck halbiert.
Also, den man sprechen,
auf 5.500 Meter,
hätte man noch 500,
und 60 kann auch 60 Hectopascalle.
Das ist auch ein Wert,
die 5.500 Meter,
wo sehr wichtig sind,
für die Türeprüfung,
sondern das Lernen.
Also der Druck nimmt natürlich in der Höhe ab.
Man kann sich auch vorstellen in der Luftdruck.
Das ist ja wie eine Luft-Sühle,
wo ob es ist,
bis der Troppospause aufhauen.
Und das ist gleich wie im Wasser, zum Beispiel,
hier, wo man tauchen darf,
dass man in dem Wasser geht.
Der Höhe ist der Druck,
die Gravitation von der Erde.
Und den man sprechen,
ist natürlich der Luftdruck,
am höchsten am untersten Punkt,
auf mehreren Höhe,
und nimmt in der Höhe ab.
Das haben wir mit der Gravitationsdauer,
und mit dieser Luft-Sühle,
wo auf uns wirkt,
und den man sprechen,
einen Luftdruck generiert.
Da die Zahlen einmal kurz zusammengefasst,
aus dem 13.255 Grad,
und die 0,6500 Meter,
das sind die Zahlen,
die für uns für die Elevante
sind, für die Standardatmosphäre.
Genau.
Und wenn man überlegt,
die Standardatmosphäre
ist natürlich nicht immer gleich,
wenn es ihren Tagen mit dem Wetter
in ihren Tagen leben.
Da kommt ein Motor dazu,
die auf der Erde scheint,
und wirkt,
und verschiedene Land,
und mehr Wasser,
verschiedene Erwärme,
verschiedene Jahreszeiten auch,
mit einer verschiedenen Israelwinkel von der Sonne je nach Jahreszeiten.
Der Kennenze ist ja nicht immer gleich hoch.
Dementsprechend kommt das Ganze geführt,
also die Standardatmosphäre
aus dem Gleichgewicht,
und es gibt Schwankungen,
im Luftdruck,
und damit eine ganze Wettersysteme.
Und das ist ganz ein wichtiger Motor,
wo
1000 Gleichgewicht bringt,
und der Wetter verschieden,
beäufelt.
Und das schauen wir jetzt zusammen an,
was das für ein E-Fluss gibt.
Die Sonne,
die auf der Erde scheint,
die Erwärme,
den Boden,
das ist ganz wichtig.
Also die Sonne,
erwärme nie eine Luftmassen,
muss ich durch die Schinte,
erwärme vielleicht die,
oder kann sich auch nicht erwärmen,
sondern es erwärmt eigentlich nur,
mit Baden-Narke-Luftschichten.
Das ist die Luftschicht,
die wirklich auf dem Boden aufleidt,
mit dieser Abstrahlungswärme,
die ihn entsteht,
und die Baden-Narke-Luftschichte erwärmt sich dann.
Und für die Erwärmung
von dieser Baden-Narke-Luftschicht
gibt es Regionen auf der Welt,
verteilt auf dem Globus,
wo sich verschiedene erwärmen.
Regionen am Equator,
erwärmen sich natürlich mehr,
wie eine Region,
die in den Polargegen,
die Luftmassen,
ist eigentlich ein Luftvolumen,
die gleiche Eigenschaften hat.
Zum Beispiel erwärmere Luftmassen
und die Kälterin.
Und das sind immer Gebiet,
die über mehrere hundert Kilometer
gleiche Eigenschaften haben,
also ein gleicher Luftdruck,
oder gleiche Temperaturen,
oder ähnliche Temperaturen,
eine Wärmere Temperaturen
oder eine Kälterie Temperaturen.
Grundsätzlich ist es so,
über die Gebiet,
wo länger Kälter ist
als Umgebung,
wird ein höherer Luftdrucken entstanden.
Und über eine Gebiet,
wo länger warm ist,
wird umgebiet,
entstanden,
tiefere Druck.
Und dementsprechend
gibt es in der tropischen Gebiet,
zum Beispiel die tropische Duftdruckgebiet
und in der Polarengebiet
gibt es die Polaren Hochdruckgebiet.
So entstehen verschiedene Luftdrucken.
Und dann entstehen aber die Duftdruckgebiet
wo man jetzt in der nächsten paar Folie draufwerdet.
Ego,
war das für das,
was das für ein E-Fluss
auf uns aus Wetter hat.
Man kann sich da vorstellen,
dass es so wie Gürtel gibt,
rund um die Welt.
Rund um die Globus,
gibt es die sogenannten Hardletzellen,
die sind die Duftdruck-
und Hochdruck-Ring.
Da gibt es noch mehr,
wie jetzt auf dieser Grafik.
Grundsätzlich ist aber so,
dass es in der tropischen Gebiet,
dass man Quartertüftdruck gibt
und in der Polarengebiet
Hochdruck-Gürtel gibt.
Und so gibt es auch tropische Luftmassen
und Polari Luftmassen.
Und auch da werden wir jetzt
in der nächsten paar Minuten lernen,
was auch für ein E-Fluss auf uns aus Wetter hat.
Da haben wir Gaka,
es gibt verschiedene Erwärmungen
von der verschiedenen Gebiet.
Dementsprechend gibt es ein Hochdruckgebiet
und ein Duftdruckgebiet.
Und da sehen wir jetzt in der Mitte zum Beispiel
die Zahl,
wo man jetzt gefahrenen kann,
von dieser Standardatmosphäre.
Die 1000-3025 und so bald,
haben wir den Luftdruck sinkt.
Und Differ ist wieder,
da werden wir vom Nicht-Düftdruckgebiet.
Da werden wir jetzt bis in Europa,
ist es sehr aus ausgepr,
die Düftdruckgebiet,
da werden wir von 955 Hector-Pascal
und sehr aus ausgeprägt,
Hochdruckgebiet,
da werden wir von 1035 Hector-Pascal.
Jetzt ist die Zeit
von globaler Erwärmung.
Wir werden leider die Werte
auch immer ein wenig extremer.
Es gibt sogar Hochdruckgebiet,
wo zum Beispiel bis 1848 Hector-Pascal reichen.
Also es sind sehr stache,
Druck und Unterschied.
Dementsprechend werden auch
die mit der
logische Phänomen immer stärker.
Und das Stärker,
wo man leider immer wieder erlebt,
mit den Unwetter zum Beispiel,
hat genau mit den Druck-Schwankegen zu tun,
dann kann man auch später
zum Zeimagen dazu in der Hochdruckgebiet
sinkert Luftmassen
und im Düftdruckgebiet
steigt Luftmassen.
Das ist dann später ganz wichtig
für ein Flugwetter,
wo man noch nicht wieder zu kommen.
Und grundsätzlich,
wie jedes Gas
oder jede Flüssigkeit
hat Luftmassen,
das Bedürfnis zu einem Druck ausgleichen.
Das heißt,
ein Luftmassen wird immer
vom Hochdruck aus Düftdruck flüssen,
weil es der Druck ausgleichen wird.
Und dämmensprechend
ist vor allem bei uns am Warten
oder in den Düfer-Luftschichten
die Luftströmung wichtig,
dass das Luft vom Hoch
ist Düf-Lüst und dämmensprechend
entsteht auch die Wind,
die Windsystem,
wo man spüren kann,
wenn der Wind blasst.
Und so gibt es
die Hochströmung,
wo für uns dann wichtig ist,
um die Windrichtungen zu erkennen
und aussen zu lesen.
Dann kann man zu den ISO-Bare-Karten
es Warten,
die sich auch schon gehört haben
oder im Theorie-Buch schon gelesen haben.
Es gibt Wetter-Karten,
wo genau die Wetter-Fanomen,
wo man es gab,
besprochen haben,
beschrieben.
Die Wetter-Karten,
die entstehen,
einerseits aus aktuellen Messwert,
wo man mit Barometer
oder Luftdruck misst.
Und natürlich auch die Computer-Modell,
die aufgrund der Messungen
das Wetter probieren,
zu prognostizieren,
und ver
für Auszurechnen.
Und dann entstehen
die lustigen Wetter-Karten,
die man jetzt auch noch genauer darauf eignen,
wie man diese auserleicht.
ISO-Bare-Karten,
ISO-Bare,
sind die Linien,
die man da sieht,
ISO-Bare,
beschrieben,
die die Biet,
die die gleiche Luftdruck haben,
oder die gleiche Luftdruck,
verurst gesagt,
wird.
Also, wenn da zum Beispiel,
von 2025 Hector-Bass,
dann sieht man jetzt auch nicht gut,
in der nächsten Karte,
kann man es einfach besser sehen.
Und überall,
wo die Linien durchgibt,
wird auf mehreren Söcke,
das ist ganz wichtig,
der Druck wird aber gerechnet,
auf mehreren Söcke,
der gleiche Luftdruck herrschen.
Von dem her kommt der Name ISO-Bare-Karten.
ISO-Gleichbleiben,
bar,
ist Druck,
überall,
wo die gleiche Luftdruck herrscht,
wird das so eine Linie aufzeichnet.
Und auf so einer ISO-Bare-Karten
sind oft auf der Fronten nicht zeichnet,
natürlich,
dann kann man den als später
in dem Kurs nachlich neuern dazu,
was mit diesen Fronten
zu sehen ist.
Da sieht man nachlich größeren ISO-Bare-Karten,
da sieht man wieder die Hochdruckgebiet,
die Öfteruchtgebiet,
und jetzt gibt es Sprachen,
wo der verschieden Luftdruck entstanden ist,
durchzunehen,
und auch die Jahreszeit zum Beispiel.
Und so sieht ein bisschen größer dargestellt
in ISO-Bare-Karten.
Ausdruck,
da sieht man immer ein bisschen anders aus,
je nach Zeitung,
oder nach einem Meteor-Service,
sieht man ein bisschen anders aus,
aber im Grundsatz sind eigentlich alle
die gleiche Elemente drin.
Das sind dann die Hochdruckgebiet,
ISO-Bare,
und die farbige Linie,
die Fronten.
Genau.
So sieht denn da aus,
jetzt haben wir von einfach zeigt,
auf unserem Globus,
die verschiedenen Druckgebiet,
wo entstehen,
auf verschiedenen Land und mehrere Messen.
Die haben verschiedene Druck,
da sind wir noch Texte im Druck.
Und die durch Kräuliskraft,
das ist ein physikalisch Phänomen,
die Erdrotation,
werdet verschiedene,
wer die Luftmassen,
wo in Bewegung kommt,
verschieden abgelenkt,
und da entstehen
so psychische Bewegungen,
also so rotierende Bewegungen,
für die Bildlich gesprochen,
ist ein Abfluss zum Beispiel,
entstehen auch die verschiedene Kräfte,
oder die Form vom Abfluss,
entstehen so ein Strudel,
wenn die Wasserabfluss in Abfluss
fängt zu rotieren,
und so entstehen so eine Drehbewegung.
In der Luftmassen ist vor allem die Kräuliskraft
ausschlaggebend,
dass die Luftmassen
auch an den Rotieren anfangen.
Dementsprechend auf den Nord,
von unserem Glowbus,
also alles Nördlach,
vom Equator,
ist es so,
dass in der Hochdruckgebiet
die Luftmassen im Urzeiger sind,
und in der Dürfdruckgebiet
im Gegenurzeiger sind.
Ich habe mir da jetzt ein bisschen Eselsburg gebaut,
dass für mich ein Hochdruckgebiet
etwas positiv ist,
weil er zu uns scheint
und schön wetter ist und Flugwetter ist.
Dementsprechend ist etwas positiv,
und für mich ist der Urzeiger,
in der Dürfdruckgebiet
im Gegenurzeiger sind.
Die Rotation.
Auf den Südlachern
haben es Fähre,
also zum Beispiel in Australien,
funktioniert das Ganze genau,
gegengesetzt,
einfach für die,
wo man in Pferiflügert
und in Südamerika flügt
oder in Australien
gegengesetzt.
Ganz niedriglich,
in der Dürfdruckgebiet
ist natürlich auch natürlich
in Fall von den Hurricane.
Da sieht man richtig,
wie die Luftmesser rotiert.
Ein Hurricane
ist nichts anderes,
als ein extremes Dürfdruckgebiet.
Dementsprechend sieht man,
da ist jetzt ein Hurricane,
ist auf den Nördlichen,
Halbcugeln,
sieht man wieder
in Gegenurzeiger sind,
rotiert und in der Dürfdruckgebiet
in eine Gesage wird.
Die Luftmesser.
Da sieht man sehr schön
auf dem Wulcherbindelt
vom Hurricane.
Dementsprechend,
in der Folie,
sieht man,
dass die Luftmesser
der Dürfdruck ausgleichen,
sie flügt vom Hochdruck
in der Dürfdruckgebiet.
Die flüste aber nicht
in einer direkten Linie
vom Hoch ist Dürf,
sondern auch in der Dürfdruckgebiet.
Zum Windrichtig.
Den Außenläsern
werden wir noch auf den Karten
schauen.
Wir werden noch ein paar Folie spätern,
wie man die Windrichtig
in den Esobarenkarten außen liest.
Wir können auch ein Windstärk
in den Außenläsern
aus dieser Esobarenkarten
füchtern noch
bildlich gesprochen
als vergleichen Esobarenkarten.
Ich kann auch immer
ein bisschen wie eine Topografiekarten lesen.
Also sind verschiedene Höhelinie,
verschiedene Drucklinie
und dementsprechend
ich habe zum Beispiel
ein Hochdruckgebiet
verschieden Hochsee.
Ein Hochdruck
Efluss dementsprechend
auch ist verschieden Starch,
man zum Beispiel ein 4.000er
vom Hochdruckgebiet.
Da ist extrem stark.
Da ist sehr viel Esobarenlinie,
sehr viel Topografielinie
von der Landschaft.
Oder es kann auch nur ein Hügel sein.
Aber der Hoch
beschreibt eigentlich nur der höchste Druck,
also die höchste Hebung
von der Landschaft
oder von dem Hügel.
Und dementsprechend kann
ein Hücher sein
oder weniger hoch.
Und dementsprechend sind
auch die Wetter E-Fluss,
wo man jetzt den Gang noch besprechen,
stärker oder weniger stark.
Wir besprechen,
schauen wir jetzt rasch auch,
wie man aus einer Esobarenkarten
ein windrichtig Außenlässt.
Wir haben grundsätzlich,
da ist jetzt so ein Infografik
aus der Therapieprüfung.
Da haben wir verschiedene Druckgebieten
immer gesehen.
Jetzt machen die Prüfung
natürlich nicht so einfach,
wo es ein H und ein Tee
einsetzt.
Und da wissen wir,
dass die Druckgebiet ist.
Dementsprechend wollen
Sie,
da sind die Druck
von den Esobaren außenlässt
und wir sehen jetzt zum Beispiel,
da bis die Kante in Navier oben,
sieht man 900,
man kann es relativ schlecht lesen.
80 Kick-Top-Bassgeld zum Beispiel,
das weiß man,
da ist unter den 1000-30,25.
Da muss es also ein Duftdruck sein.
Dementsprechend können
auch in der Vorstellungen
auch den Tee,
wo ich auch innen schreibe,
wenn er ist.
Dementsprechend wissen wir,
dass die Luftmassen
in dem Duftdruckgebiet
gegen Uhr zeigen,
rotiert.
Und nachher kann man sich
auf den Esobarenlinien,
wo man da sieht,
kann man sich,
wenn man wird,
kann man viele dritte Zeichen,
oder man kann sich natürlich
auch nur vorstellen,
kann man den Esobarenlinien
auch sich viele
darstellen,
dann ist es da,
wenn man zeigert,
und dementsprechend
wird die Windrichtung auserglesen.
Also da jetzt zum Beispiel
in England
immer ein Westwinsträumig.
Und im Hochdruckgebiet,
da immer in 3030 Hector
passt,
da haben wir die höchste Erhebung.
Der ist der Hochdruck,
der rotiert
seinem Urzeiger.
Dementsprechend
geht der Wind
da den Esobaren an.
Und dann können wirklich
für die Theorie
so, dass der Wind immer
parallel zu der Esobaren
auserglesen wird.
Also nehmen wir wirklich
die Linie
und das Windrichtung.
Weil die Wind
so eine zirkulierende
Bewegung ausgleichen
werden,
der Druck.
Genau.
Da ist für die Windrichtung
und das Windrichtung.
Ich könnte ja
auch forschen,
zum Beispiel,
als der Hoch- und Duftdruckgebiet,
ein Quineszera-Zistema-Funktion.
Ja, da können wir
vorstellen,
also wie zwei Zera-Retlen,
wo in den anderen Griefen
und dementsprechend
die Wind
muss ich auch
besser forschen,
vielleicht.
Genau.
Wenn man die Wind auserleicht,
schauen wir jetzt
gerade auf den nächsten ein paar Vorliegen an.
Das Einte,
wo für die Wind
vorelle Wand
ist,
ist Windrichtung.
Wir müssen wissen,
weil die Windrichtung erwarten
auch,
weil es starbplatz geht.
Wo ist die Windrichtung
auch für verschiedene Wetter- Phänomen?
Man kann sich
da vorstellen,
da ist ein Kompass raus.
Mit Norden-0-Grad
auf den 90-Grad,
1780-Grad
westet 207-Grad.
Dementsprechend
wird der Windrichtung
manchmal auch
gerade AG
für den 360-Grad.
Ein Windrichtung wird immer beschrieben,
von wo das Wind kommt.
Also wenn der Wind
von Süden her kommt,
dann reden wir von Südwind,
Nordwind
und Westwind,
natürlich dementsprechend
Grundlufmasse
von Westen her
und dementsprechend
ist Westwind.
Und dementsprechend
werden auch die gerade AG
also wenn man Wind
aus 90-Grad
ist ja ein bisschen die
gängige Maseinheit
für Windgeschwindigkeit.
Da können wir uns amähe
und den meisten
Wetterstationen z.B.
wird der Windich AG.
Und da
und ein natürlich
zweiten Beispiel
20-Grad.
Mal 2,
40,
minus 6,
das sind den 4,
da gibt es
360-Grad
Wind.
Die Umrichtung
ist wichtig,
dass wir die Gleufig haben
und präsenten
für die Rieprüfung.
Denn wenn man auch noch so
das Thema Wind kandet
zu eine,
ist der Wind gradient.
Wenn man sich jetzt
vorstellt,
dass jetzt meine Zierende
Windsysteme kommt,
mit einem Westwind,
und der gleitet
über die Erde
Oberfläche.
Dementsprechend ist der Wind
Wind in der hohe
Meistensstärcher.
Am Badenunnen
hat der Wind eine Rieprung.
Dementsprechend wird
der Langsamer
und er wird aber
ein bisschen duobolenta.
Also dementsprechend
gibt es
ein bisschen Grundregeln,
dass in dünn Verschicht
die Badennachgeschichte
der Wind schwächer ist,
aber duobolenta.
Und in höchere Luftschichten
ist das Stärker,
aber laminare.
Logischerweise gibt es
noch verschiedene
metrologische Phänomen,
wo ja,
vielleicht schon einmal ein
bisschen duobolenta
in die Luftmasse
in höchigem See,
oder der ganze auch
ein wenig akkieren.
Aber ein Grundsatz
ist es so,
wenn man Windströmung
kennt, ist sie am Baden.
Schwächer und duobolenta.
Genau.
Der Wind gradient.
Ein Gradient ist übrigens
immer ein Verlauf,
jetzt in den Sinn
in der Höhe.
Also temperature gradient
später im Thürikhaus
da geht es immer
um ein Verlauf
in der Höhe.
Wenn man von einem Gradient
treten,
aber in der Metologie
geht es vor allem um Thürki.
Genau.
Beim Thema Wind gehört
anderes Thema dazu,
wo für uns Klatschenflüge
vor allem wichtig ist
und das sind duobolenta.
Wenn man eine
mögliche ruhige Flug hat,
die Perspektive,
wenn sie am Otobolenta
hätten, wenn man Parazie
und wissen, warum
das die Otobolenta entsteht.
Und wie man diese auch
könnte,
vielleicht ein bisschen rausgesehen
und die Wände
gibt, dass man schlügt
und wenn vielleicht nicht.
Und da geht es
so gut zurück
und typen von
Otobolenta,
wo man unterscheidet,
wo auch in der Thürikprüfung
abgefangen werden.
Zuerst einmal sich
die Bestobolenta
einmal,
sicher angenehm sind,
aber vielleicht auch weniger angenehm,
aber die Thermistobolenta.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die hier,
wo wir am meisten ausgesetzt
sind,
bei der Flügelrei,
weil wir die Thermikflügel,
die wir entsprechend bewegen,
sind immer in der Thermischen
Luftmassen.
Und die,
die einfach schon gespürt haben,
wissen,
verwenden sie recht.
Und so geht es darum,
wenn eine Luftmassen steigt,
die Luftmassen ist
grundsätzlich
relativ ruhig,
liegt sie da
und dann steigt die Thermische
bladere auf,
wo man den später
noch Gnarierwerdetalluge
und in dieser steigenden Zonen
gibt es auch mehrmals
aussen,
um eine nachliegende Abwindzone
bei Thermischen aufwinde.
Dementsprechend
gibt es dort
der Windscherigen
im vertikalen Bereich
und in dieser Windscherigen
gespürt man natürlich
die dooblänze.
Dementsprechend
die Thermische dooblänze.
Dann gibt es
die Windscherigen
in diesem Sinn.
Da ist schon etwas,
da geht es darum,
wenn man zwei verschiedene
Windrichtungen haben,
wenn man zu ohne Westwintern
und oben haben,
oder dann ist meistens umgekehrt,
ohne wenn man sich noch
etwas bisen drin,
also Ostwind,
oben haben wir Westwind,
dann gibt es im Engmal
eine Mischschicht,
wo die zwei Windsysteme
offenandtreffend
und dementsprechend
gibt es genau
in dieser Höhemäthlinie,
wo die Wind auf einen Ankämmet
ein sogenanntes Scherwind,
und dann nehmen wir mal
auch das Dua-
oder das Licht
in die Dua-
Linze,
nach Windstärchen.
Ist für uns gleich
am Flüger
jetzt nicht so relevant,
mehrmals,
sondern auch so ein Phänomen,
dass es so ein Schicht gibt,
wo die Pizle rumpelt,
da hat mehrmals ein Metallwind,
zum Beispiel zu tun,
wo man dann auch
später drauf kämmet.
Bei dem Mechanischen
Dua- Linze,
da ist schon die dritte
Themenfeld,
gerade darum,
dass wenn ein Luftmassen
über ein Objekt strömt,
zum Beispiel ein Wald,
oder ein Haus,
oder irgendein,
oder sogar
vor allem für uns
vor Elevanz,
bin ein Berg,
kettet zum Beispiel,
wenn man jetzt starke Wind
und über die Objekt strömt.
Den anderen kennen
das durch alle
von diesen Strömungsvideos
für ihr,
wir haben eine Autos im Windtunnel,
danach gibt es
hinter am Objekt
von Wirblichen,
wo sie ja unangenehm
sein könnte,
natürlich noch Windstärke,
könnte sie ja unangenehm
sein,
oder auch geförlich,
wenn der Wind aber
ja schwach ist,
danach sind die Mengen
auf ganz finnstbürobar.
Im Landenplatz
ist dann natürlich
wichtig,
wenn man sie am wir
hinter dem Haus über die Landen,
wenn man starke Wind hat,
ist dann natürlich
nicht so vervorteil.
Da vielleicht noch zwei Wörter,
wo immer wieder mal aufkämmert,
beim Flügen,
ist Luft und Leh.
Das Thema,
wo man gerade jetzt auch
befindet,
die Lehseite
beschreibt immer die Wind
abgewandt.
Und die Luftseite
ist der Wind zugewandt.
Jetzt ist es immer gefragt,
wo ausladen wir es,
schauen wir es aus,
schauen wir es von einem Objekt aus.
Oder,
wir können auch,
wir können es sich
viel Reda am Startplatz
zum Spirrauer Berg kräten.
Dann haben wir die Lehseite,
und das ist einfach vom Berg ausgesehen,
die Wind abgewandt.
Also,
drückseiten
von dem Berg,
wenn Luftmassen
auf Dart trifft.
Oder,
in diesem Sinne,
vielleicht ein Haus,
ein Lehseite vom Haus,
und ein Luftseite vom Haus.
In den Landen wollte
genau das Gleiche.
Wir können
Luftseitungen
aber abbauen,
vom Landenplatz ausgesehen,
auf der Luftseite,
auf den Wind zugewandt.
Genau.
Zum Luft- und Leh,
insbesondere immer wieder
während der Kürriere
ihrer Ausbildung
und in der Mitte der Tür.
Dann können wir mal
zum letzten
Wetterphenomen,
wo es um den Wind geht,
wo für uns auch ganz,
ganz wichtig ist,
für Gleiche am Flüger.
Und zwar
geht es da
uns Verständnis
vom Venturi-Effekt,
und so genannten Venturi-Effekt,
können da vielleicht
aus der Errodynamik-Theorie,
können wir da drücken,
den anderen genannten Anliegen.
Im Venturi-Effekt
innen
geht es darum,
wenn immer
ein Windströmig
oder Luftmassen
dazu drängt,
wird,
zum sich verengen.
Jetzt sind
den ersten Beispiel,
zum Beispiel ein Dahl,
wenn man es bereits Dahl hat,
wo sich auf das Mal verengen.
Und der Wind,
der durchdruckt,
wird ein Dahlwind,
zum Beispiel,
auch eine Gitz,
in der Verengung
von dem Dahl,
ein Windbeflühningung.
Also da haben wir
deutlich stärker Wind,
wie
in der breite Seite
vom Dahl.
Dementsprechend,
wenn man natürlich
flügt,
wenn man viel Wind erwartet,
dass man da in einem
offenen Dahlgang
auch in einem Engen
schlitzt,
zum Beispiel.
Da ist der Venturi-Effekt.
Der gleiche Venturi-Effekt,
gibt es auch
auf dem Berg
oder auf dem Hügel.
Meine Luftmassen herkommt,
kann sich vorstellen,
einen schönen parallelen Linie,
wo der Wind herkommt.
Und nachher,
haben wir einen Hügel,
wo die Luftmassen
zum Stiegen gebracht wird
und Dementsprechend
zu einer Verengung
auf den Hügel
oder auf den Berg
geredet werden.
Und Dementsprechend
ist die Windgeschwindigkeit
auf dem Berg
oben am allersten.
Also,
wenn wir einmal auf dem Berg
gestimmt
und wenn Starten
auf den Hügel,
und es hat
sehr starker Wind,
danach ein Stiegendach,
wenn man natürlich
mit dem Glänzulat
ein paar Hundert Meter
und dann merken wir,
dass in der unteren Schicht
der meisten Wind
sehr, sehr schwächer ist,
wie wir wirklich
ganz oben
voller Kompression innen.
Ist natürlich etwas,
wo man
vielleicht beim Sohring
in der Flugpaxi-Sale
oder in der Ficht schon gemacht.
Natürlich wichtig
ist,
wenn wir genau den Bereich
bleiben,
wo es den Aufwind gibt,
wo der Wind am Stiegen ist.
Aber ganz wichtig
oben auf den Kräten
für die Meistens
zu einer Beschleunigung
von einer Wind.
Wirken,
wenn die Uri-Effekt
genau.
Jetzt haben wir Wind,
sie stehen,
haben wir auch geläugert,
durchgebiet,
hoch durchgebiet,
wenn die Lerndümmel
aus der Isobale
Wind kann ausleisen,
eine Windstärke,
vielleicht auch ausleisen,
weil die Nöcher,
dass die Isobale
zusammen sind,
desto stärker ist der Wind.
Und ihr Witter
und Land,
die Isobale sind,
denken,
eine Dopografie-Karte,
eine Landschaftskarte,
ihr Witter aus der Land,
die Isobale sind,
desto schwächer
ist die Druckgefälle,
desto,
schwächer,
ist auch die Ausgleichsteuerung
zwischen den Druckgebiet.
Es ist ganz wichtig,
dass wir auch nicht zusammensetzen,
die verschiedene Themenbereiche,
die wir jetzt anschauen,
und die Differ,
das Verständnis wird,
wenn mit den Luftmassen
passiert,
desto mehr kann man auch
nicht zusammensetzen,
und es ist so wie ein Puzzle,
Stahl, die sich so interessantin fügt,
und dann wird das Flugwetter,
wirklich zu einem interessanten Feld,
und wir haben wirklich Freude daran,
wenn man auch zusammenhängen versteht
und wirklich Basics verstaht.
Und darum ist der Kurs jetzt auch sehr wichtig,
dass man wirklich Basics verstaht,
und nicht auf etwas Auswände gelernt.
Und da werden wir jetzt noch weiterhaut,
in der nächsten Folie.
Das nächste Thema,
wo man jetzt anhaut,
eigentlich das Einzige,
wo man jetzt auf dieser Isobale k.
In der Isobale k.
Da noch nicht aeglögt,
dann sind die Fronten.
Das sind die farbige Linie,
die blaue roten und violette Linie
mit der verschiedenen Zeichen drauf.
Und die führen zu ganz speziellen
metrologischen Bedingungen,
wo für uns als Gletsch und Flüger
ganz, ganz wichtig sind,
dass man hier verstaat-
und das Mal gefahren
von den Fronten erfandt,
aber zum Fronten versta-
und dann zurück,
wie ein Fronten überhaupt entsteht,
wie ein Staatenfront.
Und zwar muss fahren ein K.
Die Luftmasse,
auf dem Globus,
er wärme sich verschieden,
mit der Kälter in die Luftmasse
ein paar Polargebieter,
und mit der wärmere fürchte Luftmasse
in der tropischen Gebieter,
oder subtropischen Gebieter.
Und wenn es vorne kann,
eine Luftmasse beschreibt,
ein Gebiet,
eine Luft,
wo Lumen,
wo einige Eigenschaften haben.
Da haben wir zwei verschiedene Luftmasse.
Und zwischen drin
gibt es eine Luftmasse Grenzen.
Und die Luftmasse Grenzen
wird beschrieben,
durch ein Front.
Wir haben die blaue Drüge,
da beschreibt ein Kaltfront,
und mit die roten Bölele,
also die Runde,
Grafiken,
da beschreibt ein Warmfront.
Und dann gibt es noch Misch-
von Auclusion,
wo man später auch noch auf die Zürge
könnt,
dass die Trittform von einer Fronten ausgibt.
Jetzt können wir auch vorstellen,
wir haben die verschiedenen Luftmasse,
und jetzt haben wir zum Beispiel
ein Duftdruckgebiet,
wo man den Wirbelen anfängt.
Stell dir da,
vielleicht den extrem fallen Herrican-Fran.
Da ist Wien Riese Wirbel,
da ist ein Mixer,
wo man anfängt,
die Luftmasse durch ein Landwirbelen.
Und dementsprechend
fangen sich auch Frontenbilden.
Ein Kalt, die Luftmasse zieht,
weil ich von Nader richtig süden.
Und wenn man die Luftmasse zieht,
von südenrichtigen Nader.
Und dementsprechend fängt ein Frontensystem,
sich auch bewegt.
Ein Luftmasse wird bewegt,
und dementsprechend ausdust.
Und so entsteht
den Schritt für Schritt die Fronten.
Da haben Sie jetzt hier feststellen,
mein Zeio Wien Richtiges,
für das Duftdruckgebiet,
wo die tieren,
wo das Ganze gespannt
die Irrothation bringt
und dementsprechend die Frontenbilden bilden.
Wenn man da,
vielleicht auch ganz schön sieht,
ist das zuerst ein Warn-Front verursgert,
die Rute-Linie,
und mindestens ein Kalt-Front,
wo hinten nachgeht.
Jetzt sieht man,
ob es nach einer Anlage erhaltbar ist,
schneller unterwegs,
wie eine Warn-Front.
Also, ein Kalt-Front
ist fast doppelt,
so schnell sich am Bewegung wie eine Warn-Front.
Und dementsprechend,
kunst dazu,
dass die Kalt-Front,
die Warn-Front,
irgendwann aufholt,
und man sieht es da im Zentrum,
vom Duftdruck,
bildet sich,
wenn die Oklusion beschreibt,
ein Mischform von den zwei Fronten.
Wir werden jetzt genauer im Detail,
darauf ego,
wenn das bedeutet,
oder wie das ausgesehen.
Wir sehen jetzt da,
wie die Luftmassen einfach nicht rotieren,
wie die verschiedenen Fronten-Systemen entstehen,
die zwei Luftmassen.
Jetzt sehen wir,
vielleicht sehr kalt-Front da.
Das ist fast die Wichtigst-Front,
oder die Gefährlachst-Front für Kleidschenflüger.
Und zwar kommt ein Kalt-Front.
Man kann sich vorstellen,
die zieht von links nach rechts in der Grafik,
die Kalt-Laufmassen
schiebt sich ohne innen.
Die ist schwerer.
Dementsprechend schiebt sie sich
sich ohne innen,
und sich unter so winnere Drop-Verfahren her.
Da können wir mal die Form
von der Linie in der Werte kale,
ist so eine Drop-Verfahren,
wo daher kommt.
Dementsprechend schiebt sich kalt,
die Luft ohne innen,
die wärmer Luft,
die schon leichter,
und dementsprechend wird sie wegstiegen.
Dementsprechend kommt es zu einer Großflächung,
zu einer Großflächung,
zu dieser Abstand.
und kann man immer Gewitter mit her.
Und jetzt sieht die Gewitter vor,
auch natürlich sehr stacher Wind, sehr stachige Böhe.
Das ist natürlich für das Klatschenflügel extrem gefährlich.
Was bei den Kaltfronten natürlich das Problem ist,
im Fahrrad oder Kalt-Front,
haben wir meistens schönes Wetter.
Es ist so eine Schie, es ist schönes Wetter.
Macht einem auch zum Flügel, vielleicht gibt es auch ein wenig Wind.
In der Schweiz ist oft mit der Westwinde ein bisschen begleitet,
oder auch ein bisschen Vönder können wir dann auch später nicht dazu.
Aber es sind meistens mit ein bisschen Wind begleitet,
aber oft gibt es gute Flugbedingungen in Gefahr der Front,
weil die Luftmassen labialisiert wird.
Es steigt, und es ist eigentlich da, wo man wöhnt.
Wenn man jetzt auch auf dieser Wetterkarte gesehen, auf dieser baren Karte,
wo man ja, hoffentlich von einem Flügen immer kurz studieren,
dass ein Karte runterherkommt,
damit man wirklich vorsichtig werden, das gleich am Flügel.
Weil damit sehr viel Wind von zusammen kommt
und damit sehr viel stiegende Luftmassen,
wo man dann wirklich schnell nicht gelandet.
Und ich glaube, die Karte Fronten ist wirklich abbrucht,
dass er in der Konservativflüge vor allem,
wenn er so eine Karte Fronten im Tag ist, von laufieren kann.
Karte Fronten kommt mit 40 bis sieber zu kamen.
Es kann relativ schnell sein, ganz wichtig.
Der Wind kann natürlich sehr viel stärker werden, die Gewitternecke.
Und sie braucht ungefähr sechs bis zwölf Stunden, bis über die Schweiz zu sagen ist.
Also kann man relativ schnell sechs sein, genau.
Also sind vorsichtig mit den Karte Fronten.
Ganz wichtig ist, wenn er jetzt im Vorfeld von der Karte von der Flüge
das er immer wieder Wetterrader erlaubt
und v.a. auch die Augen am Himmel haben.
Weil, da kann man gewitterter Herdere sieht,
ungefähr so aus.
Thema Gewitter werden wir dann auch noch genaue Erlauben im Kurs.
Aber für alle Fusssträglichen, wenn er so Gewitter in einer Linie herkommt,
wenn man auf dem Wetterrader auch wie es jetzt da aussieht,
dann ist immer extrem gefährlich.
Weil eine sehr aktive Front, die Gewitter sind sehr stark.
Und ich kann mir ein wenig wie eine Linie her.
Und wenn er so eine Gewitterlinie gesehen hat auf dem Wetterrader,
dann würde ich persönlich sehr schnell ergeländen.
Auch wenn die Gewitter noch 100 km weg sind,
weil ich auch sehr starke Wind auch verurschicken kann.
Und dann kann auch kaltluft aus Stösski von Gewitter,
wo sehr sehr gefährlich sind für Gletschernflüger.
Wo wir noch im Gewitterbereich von dem Thierrykurs
dann noch ein bisschen genaue werden.
Aber da zum Wetterrader.
Wichtig beim Wetterrader, noch ein Praxis-Typ,
schauen nicht nur auf der Radar,
sondern ein Lurgendauern Himmel,
weil die Radar bilden,
die sind meistens 40 Stunden alt,
oder halb Stunden sogar nach dem.
Lurgend, dass die Aktuellen sind,
aber Lurgendauern Himmel laufen,
und nicht nur auf die Telefon,
wenn er genug Flüge fliegen.
Genau.
Dann einen kleinen Zusatz zu den Gewitteren.
Je nachher im Zentrum,
von einem Tyftuchgebiet zum Beispiel,
dass man sich in dieser Front bewegt,
desto aktiver ist ein Kaltfront.
Wenn man nur ganz ganz am aussersten Zipfel
von dieser Front gestreift wird,
wie jetzt da im Fall von Griechenland,
kann sie, dass der ganz Wetterphenomen
einfach ein pitzliches Wetter ist
und gar nicht so mega schlimm ist,
zum Gewlügen vielleicht,
aber es sind vorsichtig,
damit wir viel mit Nachhauer zu tun.
Aber wenn man wirklich voll- voll in den Mitte
von der Kaltfrontreft verwendet,
danach ist sie wirklich sehr aktiv
und danach ist es definitiv nichts zum Flüge.
Aber wenn man nur so gestreift werdet,
kann man unter Umständen gleich noch geflügen,
und es führt zu einer Liechtenabilisierung
von den Luftmassen.
Aber da, eher für Fahrgeschrittene,
aber gut zum Wissen mit dieser Abstufung,
das ein Front im Zentrum immer stärker ist,
wie im äußersten Bereich von dieser Front.
Dann können wir zum zweiten Frontenphenomen
und das ist die Warm-Front.
Die Warm-Front ist so,
dass ein wärmerer Luftmassen
immer vorne gesehen hat,
aufgeleitet auf ein kälterer Luftmassen.
Bei so Luftmassen geht es immer darum,
welche ist kälter oder wärmer.
Da heißt es nicht passieren,
dass eine Warm ist,
man kann eine Luftmassen haben,
wo minus 20 Grad ist und die andere Luftmassen
ist minus 10 Grad,
ist auch alt,
aber es ist kälter,
als die andere Luftmassen.
Oder wärmer.
Also kommt ein wärmerer Luftmassen.
Dementsprechend ist Luftmassen
ja weniger dicht,
kleine Liechten
und sie gleitet auf der kalten Luftmassen auf.
Und dementsprechend kommt ein Warm-Front
in so einer Keilverande her.
Da können wir ein Märketeer,
die diagonalen Linien,
die Luftmassen,
die aufgeleitet,
bilden eine diagonale Linie.
Und dann macht es für uns,
die Kleid schon fliegen,
eigentlich viel weniger gefällt,
nach wie ein Kaltfront,
in dieser Trapfenform.
Und wir können ein Vorstellen.
Wenn ich es da unten auf dem Berg stand,
und wir fliegen,
dann sehen ich sehr viel,
früher noch befahrtfront,
über den Baden-Hakum,
sehe ich hohe Gewolkenschichten,
woher kommen.
Der Himmel wird immer Milchiger.
Es ist eh nicht so wirklich schön,
um zu fliegen.
Und die Luftmassen kommt immer mitbeapen.
Und den Märkmal,
wenn das nicht so gut fliegen wird,
ist es nicht so gut.
Wir sehen mal,
die Wärmfond,
viel weniger gefällt,
nach wie ein Kaltfront.
Aber logischerweise,
ich würde auch nicht in einer Wärmfond
verfliegen,
das ist natürlich auch immer mit Wind verbunden.
Wenn er auch gesehen ist,
eine Wärmfond,
die kommt sehr viel langsamer daher,
also die kommt mit 15 bis 25 kmh,
die braucht 12 bis 24 kmh,
einmal mehr,
und bis über die Schweiz auszogen ist,
also da ist meistens ein bisschen längere Geschichte.
Wenn man da zwei Tage
keine Flugwetter,
und das bringt im Vorfeld
wie es besprochen,
hohe Abschattung,
wo Edithermisch-Aktivität
schwächt
und eine wirklich gute Flugwetter bringt.
Binnerin Wärmfond
ist das einzige Problem,
was es gibt,
auch für Bergstiger zum Beispiel,
ist,
dass wenn ich da unten bin,
den gesehen ich nicht,
durch die Wolkentüren,
und gesehen,
was hin ist,
weil auch binnerin Wärmfond
kann es hin anderem
und umständige Gewitter bilden.
Also vor allem,
binnerin Oklussion,
wo man jetzt gerade zusammenkommen,
kann es hin anderem
geriesig in die Gewitterturm gehen,
wo man natürlich sehr geförlich sind,
wo er sehr starkes Wetter mit sich bringen,
handeln,
und man sieht aber gar nicht,
weil man verdeckt die wulche Schichten.
Ich finde,
über uns die wulche Nämne,
wo mit der Wärmfond
kämmert,
die wir nur den Allernern,
die wulche Nämne,
schauen wir noch einen an.
Aber,
ich bin heute zum Wissen,
die Wärmfond
kommt meistens mit der Stratos-Bew
kig, also mit der ZIRA Stratos,
der alten Stratos,
der Nimbr Stratos,
ist immer mit Stratos verbunden.
Weil das Stratos bedeutet,
und weil dafür wulche Nämne sind,
und wie ihr ausgesehen,
gehören wir dann auch
in einer anderen Kapitel,
wenn man wulche Nämne anlug.
Aber aber merken doch,
auch die ZIRA Stratos,
der alten Stratos,
der Nimbr Stratos,
wird auch an den Thierrypräufig
sehr wahrscheinlich abgefangen,
wenn die Wulche fahren,
dann kann man mal grundsätzlich
schon mal den Warm
und im Hinterkopf halten.
Genau.
Da noch einen Bildern,
wie hierher kommt,
die Wulche sehen so aus.
Das sind Schichtwulchen.
Das sind immer ganz geschlossene Geschichten
die Wulchenteckene,
die immer tiefer ablehnen,
beim Zeitverlauf
von die Frontkumpen.
Und so sehen die Wulcheformen ungefähr aus.
Dann kann man mal
zum Kapitel-Oklussion.
Oklussion,
wenn du eigentlich gar nicht extrem viel Wissen
hat die Thierrypräufigerts aber
trotzdem abgefangen.
Das ist ein Mischform,
von denen zwei Fronten.
Und wie du sprachst,
ist natürlich von uns jetzt
in der Praxis v.a. relevant.
Das bin eine Oklussion,
oft die Himmel verdeckt ist
und so genannte man es,
die gewittert gibt.
Das sind Gewittertüren,
die hinten drinnen,
weil ihr die Kalt von
die Warm von und aufholt,
ist ja schneller.
Kannst du da hinten gewittert gehen,
wenn man da vorne sind,
sieht man,
die Gewittertüren gar nicht.
Und das ist wirklich wichtig für uns,
und wir wissen,
dass das passieren kann.
Also sehr detaillierte Frage,
wo jetzt nicht extrem viel
mit Flugpaksiss zu sein hat
oder für die meisten Glacian-Piloten
nicht von großer Elevanz ist,
es gibt zwei Charakter von Oklussionen
und da wird der Bräufigert abgefangen.
.
Es gibt eine sogenannte Oklussion
mit Kalt-fronten Charakter
und Oklussion mit Warm-fronten Charakter.
Dementsprechend in so einer Oklussionsbild
gesehen mit den zwei drinnen Linien
einer von diesen Aufmassen
war einfach,
weil in D也nenMartin Ber cute
verdient guckt.
Dementsprechend
Berlinien mit Kalt-fronten 없이
敏 Kun der UX von an der BU
XiShBoyen – fragen und
und die Elemente, die da unterschiedlich sind, für normalen Flüger.
Genau.
Da wird die Aufnahme ganz kurz zusammenfassen.
So ein paar Tipps.
Das sind die zwei Kärtle, die die Tiere,
die auf die meisten Vorkämmen.
Wichtig auf der linken Karte,
zusammengefasst.
Zum Wiederholen.
Wir haben verschiedene Druckgebiet.
Überlegen, wo ist die Tiefdruck?
Wo ist der Hochdruck?
Wie erottieren?
Dementsprechend Luftmessen.
Hochdruck Uhrzeigers.
Die Tiefdruck gegen Uhrzeiger sind.
Da müssen wir schon mal die Wind-Richtig.
Wind-Richtig.
Stellen da ein Kompass rausfahren.
Aus welcher Richtig-Kunden-Winter.
Dementsprechend gerade.
Wenn die Isobaren in ihren Nähe zusammen sind,
haben wir sehr starke Winden.
Wenn sie sehr weit aus dem Land sind,
dann haben wir relativ schwache Winden.
Was heißt die Wite?
Und nach in einem Mammals-Schweizer-Sochlias-Bisspiel,
wenn die Isobaren,
wenn wir die Schweiz von der Größe nehmen,
gleich nach zusammen sind,
die Schweifhecht-O-Bass-Geschritt ist wichtig.
Dennoch ein relativ starke Wind.
Sobald die Isobaren weit aus dem Land sind,
wie die Schweiz für zwei Mal drüben und so breit,
wie die Schweiz, dann ist es wirklich schwache Windig.
Dementsprechend haben wir da im Mittelmeergebiet
sehr schwache Windig gebt.
Und dann natürlich im Zent-Zentrum
vom Hochdruck relativ schwache Windig.
Da, so Wind-Richtig und Wind-Stärke auszuressen.
Dann wird mit dem Kärtlider auch gefragt.
Dann haben wir da die Zweikarten,
da sehen wir dazu einen noch die Fronten.
Und dazu müssen, dass wir vor allem wissen,
dass wir für die Bewirkungsformen mit der Fronten dazu kommen.
Da haben wir sicher Gewitter in der Kaltfront.
Wir haben vielleicht ein bisschen komlos Bewirkung.
Und da...
Entschuldigung, jetzt ein wenig macht.
Wir haben hier einen Kaltfront.
Die Dreieckli ist ganz wichtig.
Die Formen von den Grafiken ist wichtig.
Also, wenn hier dreieckliere Kaltfronten,
da ist sicher Gewitter ein Thema.
Wir haben hier eine Warm-Front,
die vom Auslauf mit den Runden symboliert.
Dementsprechend haben wir die,
die aus Bewirkung,
wie es sich besprochen hat.
Die Dürfdruck ist im Dürfdruck,
mit den schon vierten Linien,
gar nicht der Schlag.
Da ist sicher ein Stockarm, ob ich es am Regner ist.
Und zum Beispiel eine Däne,
immer Hochdruck-Krieflug,
ist ein Multiply-Choice-Lärner,
und auch ein Dürrklicke.
Und ich erinnere da immer wieder die Grundsätze,
und mit den Zwei-Kärtchen zu besprochen haben.
Genau.
Dann sind noch gut vorbereitet.
Auf die Brühe war ISO-Bare-Karte und die Vorrunde nahe.
Dann können wir zu einem riesigen Thema,
die wichtig ist,
in der Dürfie-Lärne verschoben.
Wenn man wirklich gut gleich am Flügen will,
wenn man sich strecken will,
dann ist der Termik.
Ich würde mal vorstellen,
dass ich kurz ein Paus mit etwas trinken,
als der Karpf auslüftet,
der Kurs gar nicht noch richtig lang,
mehr noch richtig viel zu besprechen.
Dann werde ich jetzt einen Zip-Punk,
weil man das nächste Karpit-Lasche ibt.